it's easy to build it up into this like
crazy thing but then really when you're
on set with a group of people of you
know for the most part they're just
normal human beings and you just have
regular conversations with photographers
and stylists different the real world I
would say just not to think about it
very much not to take it too seriously
you know I think for most models getting
into the industry you start thinking
about what you could do and you know in
most industries there's many things that
you could do and work harder to get
better at what you're gonna do to become
successful and for me in the modeling
industry it's just not really the case
and you really have to just find
something else to focus on it favorite
part of my body my brain you can change
one thing about your I have a gigantic
head
sometimes it's raise me off balance and
I trying to flips all my friends do
flips
they're very talented at going upside
down and coming right-side up and I just
stay upside-down when I try and do for
it if you Molly will you be doing
probably more of what I'm doing now I'm
kind of like going to school full-time
I've got a kind of remote piece of
property that I have spent some time
living on and working on and that's kind
of been a big
and what would you do what's the perfect
day out for you
perfect day off surfing is kind of like
waving a passion